[Music]
let's go to marina in waterloo
where napoleon may be buried what's up
marina
not much how are you good sorry we had
to do a bunch of uh intros over again
because i'm terrible at this job how are
you
i'm doing okay excellent excellent so
what's going on
so i need to figure out how to be a big
sister and not a parent to my younger
siblings
now that we are all adults yes so tell
me about
how did you get stuck in that role as a
kid
um
well in
2004 my dad deployed overseas i was
about 11.
then and i have five younger siblings
and
after that he was just kind of in and
out so
my mom switched to basically a single
parent who was at work most of the time
so it kind of fell on me to make sure
that
the kids homework was done they were fed
they were up in time for school chores
got done all that kind of stuff
did was that ever discussed or did that
just fall on you
it
i just kind of assumed the
responsibility because it felt like if i
didn't then nobody would
can i just tell you i'm sorry that was
your childhood
me too i'm sorry
i mean i
i'm grateful for your old man's service
that's awesome and
i'm confident your mom was doing what
she could to keep things going and i'm
sorry that that fell on you it wasn't a
child's job to raise five kids
yeah
so how old are you now
28 28 how old is your youngest sibling
20.
oh gosh there was six of y'all in a span
of eight years
yes holy moly
wow
that's a lot of humans in a short amount
of time
are they all biological kids
yes
wow
okay
so there's six of y'all
tell me what you're struggling with now
um
i just kind of want to be i think the
relationships i struggle with most is my
youngest two brothers they're number
four and number five okay an order and i
want to be like a safe place for them
not somebody that they're worried about
disappointing or
judging them for
the stumbles they have through life
yeah do you all live by each other
you're all scattered across yeah we're
all within like 45 minutes of each other
that's fantastic so what's your
relationship like with your mom and dad
now
uh i don't talk to my dad and
my relationship with my mom goes from
rocky to okay back and forth okay
why don't you talk to your dad
um he
moved and decided that he didn't want to
talk to any of his children anymore
and then
uh struggles with
a drug addiction so we kind of
me and my husband decided it wasn't
safe to try and pull him back in with
our young kids so yeah tell me about
your your house you got little ones
yes i have a eight-year-old a
six-year-old and a four-year-old
dude you're you're repeating the process
huh
yeah if you hustle if you hustle you can
have two more so you can have no no i
was done having kids at 23. so
oh man
so
what you experienced as a young kid
i'm going to classify as trauma is a lot
and my guess is your mom was going
through a lot your dad was going through
a lot
and you experienced trauma and you've
got some open-ended relationships that
should be closed-ended relationships
meaning your mom and dad have never been
a safe place to anchor into
no which has left you untethered through
your whole life
what was what was some of your coping
strategies into your late teens early
20s or you got married early
yeah i got married in 2015.
my oldest is not my husband's child well
she's been adopted now but
so i had that struggle and so did you
have some adventure years
uh
not really
okay you went from
i got pregnant at 19. so okay okay went
from being a parent to my siblings to
being a parent to my kid wow
so i wrote down here while you were
talking just on my little notepad here
that you've got to reclaim your
childhood
and i know you're 28 and you feel like
you're 100 years old because you've
lived 100 years
but you're still in your 20s and so as
an old man i want to tell you and i'm
not really an old man but just older
than you
you're just a kid and i want you to
reclaim your childhood so what does that
mean when you've got three kids a
husband you got responsibilities you got
mouths to feed
when's the last time you laughed so hard
diet coke came out your nose
uh
never
right
when's the last
like
super
romantic
smoking hot weekend away you and your
husband have had
we've only done like two overnights
since we've had kids away from them yeah
when's the last time you ate and then
you ordered dessert and you just ordered
a second one
just cuz
never right
so there's a little girl in there
that is dying to laugh real real hard
and when i say dying i'm i mean that
and there's a
lovely
sexy
connected 24 year old in there
that looks at that husband and goes
she's in there too
and there's a 16 year old and a 19 year
old and a 24 year old and a 28 year old
that would love just to dance in the
living room
and i want you to discover her
because she's in there
and what i want you to start
allowing into your life something you've
never allowed in there before
because you've been an adult since you
were 10
is joy
laughter
desire
rambunctious sex with your husband
more laughter
eating healthy most of the time and just
eating garbage once a week just to be
silly
and here's where that loops back to your
original let me just stop there how does
that sound does that sound like madness
or does it sound awesome like when i say
that what it sounds
great but i don't know how to get there
because i'm always
so
worried about like what needs to be done
and needs to be taken care of yeah i
don't know how to
like let go of that
and it's not going to be an either or
it's going to be both because your kids
still got to eat and they still got to
go to bed at night
the way it works
is you were born into a story
which is your job is to start parenting
at 10.
you were told a story about here's what
your value is your value is to make sure
everybody else is okay
your value is you take your laughter and
shove it down you take your sexuality
and shove it down you take your fill in
the blank and shove it down
that little girl who just wants to dance
around the living room to
old hip-hop she needs to be quiet
because we got to get our homework done
that's the story you're born into and
what i want you to do is to imagine a
new story what would you write
what i want
i want to
feel better when i wake up in the
morning i want to have more sex i want
to have more laughter i want to start
dancing in my living room all these
whatever that looks like for you i want
to start horse riding lessons i don't
know what it is you can become a jiu
jitsu practitioner
but i want you to go out with your
husband get a
babysitter
get somebody in your neighborhood or get
one of your siblings to watch your kids
and i want you all to go out
and create something incredible it could
be whatever you want it to be
and then what you're going to do is
you're going to this is the magic word
that i want you to keep in your mind
you're going to practice
because it's all going to feel weird
and it's going to feel like you're
violating some sort of value system it's
going to feel awkward
i don't know how to dance i don't know
how to laugh really loud
i know how to be quiet because i don't
want to wake a baby up
i don't know how to just get a
babysitter and go with my husband and
have a great weekend away two weeks away
where we don't think about our eight and
our six and our four-year-old because
they're taken care of
you have to practice those things
and you're going to fail at some of them
and you're going to get tired at some of
them and you're not going to work at
some of them and that's okay
to be curious about it when you practice
why didn't that work this time let's try
it again last time here's what i'm
getting at
i don't want you to wake up and be 50
and realize that you never laughed hard
i want you to have joy in your life and
it was taken from you at a young age
now ask to answer your original question
with your brothers and sisters
i want you to call it out
call a meeting
take everybody to the cracker barrel
whatever it happens to be
and so from this point forward i'm your
sister i'm not your mom
that's my job
and we're gonna be silly
and i'm gonna go first
and so you're gonna have to go first and
lead the relational change
but i want you to speak out loud what
you want it to look like so speak it out
loud what do you want it to look like
i just want to be able to get together
with them and have fun and not all be so
drowning in
our past that we can't have a good time
together so what is it
what does fun look like
being ridiculous i know but what does
that look like
just having a barbecue and playing
cornhole and throwing water balloons at
each other
yeah
okay i want you to set that up
and when you set that up i want you to
make a few rules we are not allowed to
talk about dad we're not talking about
mom
this is just kids having fun
and you can call it sunday fun day and
once a month have all your brothers and
sisters over to your house just to be
chaotic
and be silly and just we're just gonna
have moon pies and marshmallows and
whatever i'm gonna call it diabetes i
don't care what you do but
set it up
and live it
and it's go again this could be
something you practice because there's
going to be some moments where
your brothers and sisters don't have to
be safe either they don't have to feel
safe you don't know how to feel yeah
and so y'all gonna have to practice
feeling safe what's it like to go over
to big sister's house
have barbecue have a cheap burger
and play corn hole and sit outside and
drink cheap beer and then just go home
like we don't
there's no fights there was no
discussions no whatevers like what is
that like
you have to practice it
but here's what i think
i think if you set the stage they would
love a big sister and they would love a
friend and they would love somebody they
can lean into but isn't gonna lecture
them when they start doing stupid stuff
that 21 year olds do
yeah
and we're all going to watch the latest
whatever movie that's coming out we're
all going
and everybody pay their own way i'm not
paying for everybody i don't make that
kind of money but we're all going except
for you tom you got to stay and keep all
the kids like whatever
that's big sister stuff but i want you
to just to visualize it and write it
down and go i want you to stay away from
words like i just want to have fun
i just want to be ridiculous i want you
to be really specific because if you
just say i just want to have fun that
bar tends to move on us as we're as
we're sitting there
like we could be having more fun we
should have a pool we should have done
it
like my picture is we're all sitting in
lunches around a fire pit eating hot
dogs i'm gonna make that picture happen
you got what i'm saying
yeah
do you think you're worth that
sometimes
i want to tell you you're worth that all
the time
you knew who else was worth that
those three little kids
because you know who hurt a lot too your
mom
yeah
and you absorbed her tension
you absorbed her
lack of
self-respect you absorbed her marital
challenges and i don't want that for you
and i don't want that for your kids
i want them to think back my mom was
bonkers she was hilarious she was always
turning all the lights off and playing
hide and seek in the house
she was building giant pillow forts with
us
she was always telling us to leave and
then she turned on this really swanky
dance music and she would lock the door
with that in there i don't know what
they were doing but it makes me have the
heebie-jeebies like
whatever it is
i want those to be the memories of your
mom i mean if your kid's memories of you
is that fair
yeah would your husband lean into that
with you
yeah he's super goofy
excellent live into the goofy
but my the big takeaway here is you got
to go first and lead by example with
your siblings
you have to be really intentional very
clear about what you want to do and then
i want you to go make it happen and be
really graceful with yourself because
it's going to be awkward and weird you
have to practice it the whole way
and you
are
worth it
oh my gosh you're worth it your
husband's worth that your kids are worth
it you are worth it so grateful for you